paraben is an estrogen-like compound  that is under this class of what we call  paraben I really hate this genre of like  dudes who don't understand science  trying to explain science the EU  Regulators actually looked at all of the  evidence on propyl paraben in 2021 and  this is what they found it is safe when  used in cosmetic products like they use  currently in fact they found that even  if you use it in 17 different products  with really high amounts of propyl  paraben you still get 12 and a half  thousand times less than an amount that  they would still consider safe  they also said this the estrogenic  activity of propyl paraben is extremely  weak it is thousands of times less  strong than natural estrogen big Brands  like CeraVe make pretty much the safest  products you can buy they're made by  chains of scientists who understand the  science more than dudes who film the  cells pointing at things in supermarkets